why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so with the infinity War what we're
going to find is that like The Infinity
Gauntlet we're going to be covering a
lot of stuff in each individual video
because these Comics are chalk full of
information Jim Starin did quite a good
job covering the events as they took
place directly after The Infinity
Gauntlet and what we're going to find
here is a mishmash of things most
notably we're actually going to find
Thanos switching sides and as The Story
begins to come to an end what we're
going to see is that an incredible ruse
was done an incredible trick took place
with regards to the actions of Thanos
and the main villain of this story but
what we see as we pick up with this is
that again if you recall our discussion
about The Infinity Gauntlet we had
talked about how once the event was over
that Thanos had relegated himself to a
peaceful life he had stepped away from
uh his attempts to take over the
universe and is simply just more or less
gone into a reclusive nature and so one
of the things he had done is he had
taken his previous Garb and he had
hoisted it up on a scarecrow of sorts
and so as we open this story we see what
appears to be another version of Thanos
wearing the exact same outfit that he
normally wears approaching the home of
the normal Thanos and what we see here
is that this duplicate of Thanos this
doppelganger as we'll later figure out
is uh approaching the front door and
when he opens it the real Thanos is of
course standing inside analyzing some
kind of a data pad and when Thanos turns
around to see who it is at standing at
the door there's no one there and so
what he does is he walks outside to look
around but when he does the doppelganger
Thanos is hiding behind a tree and so
from here we pick up with the real
Thanos and Thanos is speaking with his
computer while at the same time
analyzing the information that's been
given to him and what the computer says
is that the Telemetry has been gained or
has been accessed for whatever it is
that Thanos is looking at and the
computer says a Thanos will most likely
need to uh I guess examine the
information that's been given before he
actually travels to the location of
whatever it is he's discovered and so
what we learn here is that there's some
kind of a transdimensional anomaly
that's taken place out in space there's
something going on here that appears to
be a uh I guess a rift of sorts between
our Dimension the Earth 616 Dimension
and another dimension somewhere else but
again this is all just hypothetical
stuff Thanos doesn't really know exactly
what's going on here and so what the
computer says is that it's launched a
probe and the probe is designed to uh
travel towards this Rift and presumably
gain as much information and possibly
even travel through the rift if it can
now what the computer says is that the
uh probe will most likely be destroyed
here but Thanos says this is irrelevant
that the only thing that really matters
here is that the uh the probe is able to
gather the information Thanos needs and
transmit that information back and the
probe is successfully able to do that
and what Thanos tells us here is
something very very important Thanos of
course as we had seen in The Infinity
Gauntlet had wielded absolute power
power and so there really were no
Mysteries with regards to the universe
for him and even after The Infinity
Gauntlet event going forward very little
is actually surprising to Thanos due to
the time that he had wielded The
Infinity Gauntlet and so as Thanos is
going over these readings he comes
across something that is very surprising
to him that he says that he's never
really seen any readings like this
before which indicates to us that
whatever it is that's taking place here
is beyond the scope of thanos's
understanding of the known universe
indicating this could very well be
something that takes place in an
alternate Di menion that has somehow
managed to pour into our universe and so
when the computer asks Thanos what
conclusion he's come to Thanos says
there's only real one conclusion he can
draw that conclusion being that the
universe is in grave Peril and so we
pick up with Thanos as he's uh switched
out his Garb his I guess his monk-like
uniform for his normal armor and of
course the computer asks whether or not
on-site research is required here and
Thanos says yes Thanos says that
sometimes the only real way to
understand what's going on with
something is to actually travel to it
and to investigate and so the computer
offers to reconstruct another one of the
Flyers that Thanos has of course we had
seen this flyer during the uh Infinity
Gauntlet and the uh the the Thanos Quest
stories but Thanos of course tells us
that the previous design had been
destroyed but the Thanos never really
forgets any form of Technology once he
learns about it which tells us that of
course this ties into his intellect and
while the computer says that the
previous flyer had some sort of mystical
qualities most likely given to Thanos by
Mr death Thanos says that this flyer
lacks those mystical qualities but that
the uh the purpose of the flyer will
suffice and that it will allow him to
teleport throughout the cosmos and
arrive at whatever this anomaly happens
to be and this is a very interesting
part here what the computer does is it
asks Thanos whether or not he can
provide any kind of ETA for when he'll
get back and Thanos says the question is
not when he'll get back the question is
will he get back indicating to us that
what's taking place here may very well
lead to the Doom of Thanos that Thanos
himself recognizes and so from here we
switch to Peter Parker as he's traveling
through New York and as Peter Parker
describes it to us this is a pretty uh
mundane night there really isn't a whole
lot going on here but as Peter Parker is
traversing through the city we realize
that Peter Parker is being watched and
Peter Parker is being watched by the
doubleganger now for those of you guys
who are relatively familiar with
Spider-Man albeit not in an in-depth way
but are familiar with the character of
doubleganger but we're curious about his
Origins this is it this is when the dble
ganger First shows up in Spider-Man
comics during Infinity War issue number
one this is the version of Spider-Man
that is in effect exactly like him uh
with regards to uh his physical
appearance with the exception of the
fact that of course he has six arms and
some Claws and whatnot but again what we
see is that as Spider-Man is going to
the city that this doppelganger begins
to follow Spider-Man now from here we
pick up with a very interesting
development what we learn here is that
galatis was apparently doing the exact
same thing that Thanos was doing that he
was izing this transdimensional anomaly
but what what Galactus has come across
is a catatonic eternity indicating to us
that whatever power is in possession of
uh whatever was able to create this
transdimensional anomaly also has the
same power that could uh could place
eternity in a catatonic State and
because eternity is the foremost
authority or I guess the foremost most
powerful being in the earth 616 Universe
it stands to reason that whatever it is
it's going on here is a power that
supersedes eternity possibly indicating
maybe the return of the beyonder or
something like that we don't quite know
what's going on here and Galactus even
goes as far as to say this Galactus says
whatever power whatever forces are about
that have caused this are forces that
cannot be allowed to continue unchecked
they're forces that cannot be allowed to
continue unchallenged something has to
step in the step in the the way of
whatever these forces are and bring
their reign to an end now in addition to
galatis analyzing this uh analyzing
eternity in a in a catatonic State we
also see that Thanos has arrived now
whether or not Thanos and Galactus are
aware of the other's presence is
something we don't know what we do know
is that Thanos is analyzing the idea of
Eternity being in a t in a catatonic
State and what Thanos says here is that
the energy readings he's picking up are
strangely familiar they're energy
readings that he recalls to a degree but
he can't touch on which tells us of
course that whatever energy readings
these are are not based on the Infinity
Gauntlet that surely if uh these
readings were based on someone who had
somehow managed to defeat the infinity
watch and capture all of their infinity
gems that Thanos would immediately
recognize the signature because this
event takes place so closely after the
events of uh of The Infinity Gauntlet
and so again as Thanos is examining uh
eternity as he's examining this
situation he notices out of the corner
of his eye a version of himself that's
standing on an asteroid but a split
second later that version is gone and
this takes Thanos by surprise a little
bit Thanos really isn't sure what to
make of this and so from here we switch
to Tony Stark and again the one thing to
keep in mind is that when it comes to
the relationship between Tony Stark and
Iron Man at this point in the Marvel
Comics people don't know that Tony Stark
is Iron Man as far as they know the
story is still true that Iron Man is The
Bodyguard of Tony Stark and so what we
learn here is that Tony Stark had been
spending the weekend in Las Vegas and
presumably had created some kind of a
ruse or some kind of a situation that
allowed him to leave and to take on the
role of Iron Man to go about making sure
that things are safe that uh that he's
able to uh travel back to his home and
make sure that the city is in good
standing but before he's able to travel
too much farther his armor informs him
that someone's locked on to him and when
he looks back he realizes there's a
doppelganger of himself that's chasing
him and this is what we're going to see
in this comic we're going to see
doppelgangers of various characters
encounter their originals but we won't
find out until later on why it is these
doble gangers are here or who was that
had created them and so what we do is we
switch back to Thanos and at this point
it appears that Thanos has found a way
to transcend to enter the
transdimensional rift and to actually
see what's on the other side and when he
gets through this Rift he sees what
appears to be a massive Shrine of some
kind and indeed Thanos says this Shrine
reminds him a lot of the shrine he had
made for mistress death and so this
Citadel of sorts is something that he he
likes it's something that he uh really
enjoys due to the fact that it brings
back uh great memories for him in terms
terms of uh of his affection for
mistress death now from here we pick up
with Thanos as he gets to basically the
front door of the Citadel and what
Thanos tells us is that this front door
doesn't have any kind of as centy or any
kind of automated uh I guess um systems
guarding it and so Thanos comes to two
conclusions here the first conclusion is
that uh this may very well be an
abandoned Outpost that somebody was here
at one point but they're not here
anymore but in a more uh dangerous
situation the second conclusion is that
there may there may very well be
somebody here but because this person
possesses a vast amount of energy
they're not concerned about anyone who
would show up here because their power
would allow them to eliminate this
person entirely but Thanos because of
his curiosity and because of the fact
that he knows that a conclusion has to
be uh has to be created or a conclusion
has to be discovered regarding this
whole thing uh proceeds inside of the
Citadel and when he does he discovers
what appears to be a massive gem
possibly a massive Infinity gy gym that
is being uh perhaps powered or else
having its energies channeled by a giant
piece of machinery and so as Thanos is
continuing to explore here we pick up
with uh with wolverin and wolverin is in
uh in nature this is basically
Wolverine's way of being able to
meditate is his way of being able to uh
come to grips with uh I guess coming
into contact with his more primitive
self it allows him to really hone his
skills in terms of his senses as well as
his fighting prowess but as he's moving
about in nature he comes across another
Doppel ER of himself now this
doppelganger is different from Wolverine
in several ways as we can see of course
this doppelganger is wearing different
colored clothing more notably it doesn't
have three adamantium claws but instead
has claws coming from its fingers now we
don't know whether or not this
doppelganger actually has adamantium or
whether it doesn't have adamantium and
if it did not have adamantium it would
make it very easy prey for Wolverine due
to a combination of his healing factor
and the indestructible metal that covers
his bones and so what we see is that the
two of them begin toage engage in combat
with one another and what we do is we
switch back to Thanos as he's continuing
to examine this gem now thanos's idea
here is to perhaps take a piece of this
gemm and take it back to his base for
some kind of Investigation but before
he's actually able to do that someone
comes up from behind him and asks Thanos
whether or not he truly intended to take
a piece take a sample of this gym back
to his home when Thanos turns around it
seems as though Thanos recognizes who
this who this person is by addressing
them as you and so what we do before we
find out who this person is is we jump
to Dr Doom and Dr Doom again like
galatis and Thanos is examining this
transdimensional Rift it's examining
this anomaly and what he comes to the
conclusion of is saying that whatever
power it is that is uh that is based
with this anomaly whatever energy
readings are emanating from this anomaly
is very similar to the same kind of
energy readings that are usually
controlled by a cosmic entity telling us
this is a vast amount of power and so
what Dr Doom tells us here what he says
is that while some individuals would
look at this anomaly and be fearful
while they would be terrified of it Dr
Doom looks at it and says this is an
opportunity this is an opportunity for
him as he's tried so many times before
to gain absolute power but what Dr Doom
says is that his ability to uh go
further with his investigations with his
studies is limited by the technology of
his time which is very interesting to us
because Dr Doom as one of the most
intelligent people on the planet uh is
very advanced in terms of his technology
and so what he says is that he's going
to have to go to someone whose
technological understanding is beyond
his scope where at the very least the
person's ability to access technology is
beyond anything that he's capable of and
so what we do is we switch to readed
Richards to for freedoms Plaza and again
Reed Richards like Dr Doom and Thanos
and Galactus is examining this anomaly
and as he's as he's examining this
anomaly and going over these various
readings we see that some kind of a hand
that appears to be a a version of his
own reaches up from behind him and what
we do is we switch to this conflict
between the doppelganger of Reed
Richards and Reed Richards himself and
this presents a very interesting uh
conflict here because again because Reed
Richards is able to stretch his body
because he's able to move various parts
of his body in ways that normally aren't
done both the doppelganger and Reed
Richards engage in this very snake-like
kind of combat where they get so
intertwined that we don't know who's who
we have no idea which hand belongs to
which but what we see is that one of the
hands goes to reach for some kind of a
of a laser gun and is able to pull the
laser gun down but another hand tries to
stop this person from using the laser
gun so again we don't know which hand
this belongs to now the laser gun is
fired and one of the Reed Richards is
either killed or knocked unconscious and
what we see is that another version of
the Reed Richards the one who was able
to come out on top in this conflict has
his back turned to us so we don't know
if this is the doppelganger Reed
Richards or if this is the actual Reed
Richards and so what we do is we pick
back up again with Thanos and of course
what we see is that Thanos is conversing
with this unknown individual presumably
the individual who's the person behind
this transdimensional Rift and the
incapacitation of Eternity and what we
learn here is that this person is the
Magus that the Magus the evil
counterpart of Adam Warlock has returned
to uh to reality now we don't know yet
how this was done and we actually won't
find out until Infinity War issue number
two but the Magus again is uh as we
previously talked about the evil version
of Adam Warlock who seeks to take over
this reality to basically take all
forces or all life in this reality adapt
them into The Universal Church of Truth
and then force them into a position
where they will worship him as a God and
so what he says here to Thanos is that
Thanos probably didn't expect to see him
again Thanos probably didn't expect to
see him at all and so what we see is
that is that the maggus and Thanos begin
talking to one another and this is one
of the interesting relationships between
Thanos and and the Magus despite the
fact that at this point in time they
have opposing ideologies they have a lot
of respect for one another to a degree
due to the vast amount of power they
possess but because of the uh the
lengths they will go to to achieve their
own ends now this respect is tentative
at best meaning that it could it could
is very fragile and it could come to an
end at any time but as they're talking
we of course see that the Magus
references mistress death about how
mistress death had previously claimed
Thanos as her own as her partner to a
degree with that you know of course
Thanos says that she had rejected him
due to his actions with the infinity
Gauntlet and The Infinity Gauntlet event
but again what uh the Maga says here is
that there's more than one way to come
back from the dead there's more than one
way for him to reconstitute himself now
whether or not this means that the
maggus knows how he came back to reality
is something we don't know what we'll
find out in Infinity Gauntlet or
Infinity War issue number two is how it
was the Magus reconstituted himself but
it was actually a subconscious action by
Adam Warlock and so it may very well be
the Magus had just popped up into
existence and didn't know how he got
here but what we also see with Thanos is
that he taunts the Magus a little bit
and referring to the Magus as the shadow
of Adam Warlock that the war that Adam
Warlock is the real person and the Magus
is simply just a darker part of him
which to a degree is true on a more
physical and philosophical level but of
course this is one of the bins of the
Magus he hates being referred to as the
shadow of Adam Warlock and so what we
see here is that we switch back to both
Iron Man and Wolverine as both of them
are fighting their dble gangers and it
seems as though they're both putting up
a very good fight they're doing the best
they can to combat the uh copies of
themselves these twisted and uh and
mutilated versions of themselves but
ultimately we see with this conflict
that wolver rain appears to be the one
that comes out on top with his
doubleganger but that ultimately Iron
Man appears to be defeated by his now we
don't exactly know what the purpose is
of these doppelgangers being here of
course with them being doppelgangers
normally they would take the place of
the person they've defeated which is the
the entire reason behind a Doppel ganger
but because this doppelganger is so
different in terms of his physical
appearance to Iron Man there's no way
that it could successfully replace Iron
Man at least not in terms of how it
looks right now but when Wolverine kills
his doppelganger another very
interesting thing happens Wolverine's
doppelganger just disappears entirely
and so Wolverine begins to set off but
we don't know exactly where it is that
he's going now from here we switch back
to galatis and galatis of course is
talking with Nova now this version of
Nova is different from the one of
Richard rer Richard Ryder of course
became Nova through the Nova core and so
on and so forth this version of Nova is
a Herald of Galactus and her name is
Frankie and she of course possesses
power Cosmic the same powers to a degree
that the Silver Surfer had but she's
able to manipulate her energies in the
form of a physical flame that manifests
itself as her hair but she's talking
with Galactus here and Galactus as he's
explaining it to her is analyzing this
transdimensional Rift but the problem
here is that he can't get past it he
can't penetrate this uh this this Rift
due to the fact that there are mystical
properties that are guarding it and so
what he says is he's going to need the
help of somebody else to get him past
this Rift and that person as we as it
appears is going to have to be doctor
strange and we get a little bit of a
glimpse here with regards to Spider-Man
what we learn with Spider-Man is of
course that he had encountered his
doppelganger he apparently had defeated
his doppelganger and the way that
Spider-Man is reacting here in the form
of appearing to be totally exhausted
that it was most likely a very in-depth
conflict between the two of them but
from here we pick up with Iron Man and
what we learn is the whole purpose of
these doppelgangers that these
doppelgangers are apparently defeating
their counterparts and then they're
replicating their bodies now what they
do with the original bodies is something
we don't know we don't know what
happened to the actual body of Tony
Stark it may very well be that the body
of Tony Stark has been assimilated or
has been absorbed into the body of the
doppelganger and that if this
doppelganger is killed that the body of
Tony Stark will be spit back out we
don't really know what would happen at
this point but what we see is that once
this doppelganger is able to effectively
copy Tony Stark that it'll go about the
process of doing whatever it is that it
was assigned to do now from here we pick
back up with Thanos again and Thanos
again is continuing to converse with uh
with the warlock or with the maggus and
is trying to find out what it is the
maggus is doing trying to understand
what it is that the Magus is coming to
but what what Thanos does is give us
some very valuable insight into his mind
specifically after he had gained and
been defeated with The Infinity Gauntlet
and what he tells the maggus is that the
maggus is very disconcerting to Thanos
and the idea here is that the Magus is
looking to possibly use whatever
energies he's been able to attain to
again try to take over the normal Earth
616 universe and when the maggus asks
why it is that Thanos thinks this Thanos
says the reason is because he looks at
the maggus and the maggus is already in
possession of incredible power he's able
to manipulate the power Cosmic he
basically has the same power as Adam
Warlock yet there's still a desire for
Conquest in the magus's eyes he still
pursued more power and in a lot of ways
the current mindset of the maggus
reminds Thanos of himself when he was
going after The Infinity Gauntlet and so
what we do is that as the two of them
are going through the Magus begins to
realize what it is that's going on here
with Thanos that there's a difference
here that Thanos as he appears now is
not the same kind of Thanos the Magus
had previously encountered when the two
of them had come into conflict before
the magus's timeline had been destroyed
the Magus refers to Thanos as a weaker
version of himself he says that Thanos
doesn't really have the same Edge that
he used to that thanos's priorities are
entirely different here and of course
Thanos is not very uh receptive to this
he's a little irritated by this but
again Thanos is trying to figure out
what the motivations what the uh the
attempts are I guess the bases behind
the magus's actions are here but as the
Magus begins to understand what's going
on as he begins to uh to pick up what it
is that that Thanos is trying to do here
he basically uh institutes or I guess
brings in all these different versions
these different dble gangers of
superheroes that have apparently been
created among these doble gangers we of
course see most of the X-Men we see
xfactor we see Nova alphaflight pretty
much all the individuals that uh we
would expect to see among the most
prominent groups in Marvel Comics at
this time and so one of the last things
that the Magus tells Thanos is to let
Adam Morlock know that he's coming which
is a very very dire thing here and the
reason why is because if the Magus wants
warlock to know that he's going to be
there then the maggus must be capable of
incredible Feats powers that are far
beyond the scope of anything any of the
superheroes on in the earth 616 Universe
are able to utilize and this is
something Thanos recognizes Thanos says
that whatever it is that's taking place
here whatever the schemes are that uh
that the Magus is getting into are going
to uh probably lead to the to the ruin
of the entire universe it's going to
lead to the destruction of all and so
what he says is he can't do this on his
own he can't defeat uh the Magus on his
own that he's going to need help in
winning this conflict
now another thing that we see is that
the doppelganger of Thanos is speaking
with the Magus and what this
doppelganger is saying is that the
Telemetry the destination that Thanos
has set for itself or set for himself is
exactly as the Magus had predicted
indicating that the Magus has been
playing Thanos this entire time or at
the very least expects Thanos to follow
a certain course of action which is
exactly what Thanos does now what we do
from here as we switch to the Avengers
headquarters and when we get to The
Avengers headquarters we see that Reed
Richards is calling a meeting among
various superhero groups of course he's
calling the Avengers he's calling the
X-Men and he's calling the new Warriors
and he's basically telling them all the
same thing that uh there was some kind
of a a doppelganger that had encountered
him and that had tried to kill him or
presumably defeat him and most likely
take over his physical body of course he
also says that whatever forces are at
play here whatever um energy readings it
is that he has picked up are energy
readings that are quite possibly uh on
the same level or even greater than the
power of the beyonder or the infinity
gon which tells us that this is a
massive amount of power what we also see
is that Reed Richards reaches out to the
West Coast Avengers to X Factor and to
Alpha flight and he of course tells them
pretty much the same thing of course all
these groups are watching this
transmission at the same time he's not
going in sequence and speaking to each
individual group but what we have going
on here is Reed Richards telling them
they all need to come to a meeting that
he's created they all need to meet up at
Avengers or I'm sorry at a at a for
Freedom's Plaza and they all need to
basically talk about what's going on
here they need to converse about what's
taking place now from here we switch to
doctor strange and Doctor Strange is of
course in his Arcanum he's going about
whatever his normal actions are
meditating but before he's able to
meditate too much further he's exposed
to a blinding a blinding flash of light
and from here we don't really know what
happens with this character next but
what we do is we switch to Dr Doom and
Dr Doom is speaking with some unnamed
individual he's saying that again that
uh the the data that's been sent to this
person should be sufficient uh incentive
for this person to join Dr Doom in his
conquest and what Dr Doom says is that
he would never go about the process of
of going uh going along this endeavor by
himself he would never try to figure out
what this is on his own due to the vast
amount of power that is involved here
but he says that this person is the only
one person that Dr Doom can trust but
what he also says is that the two of
them working together could be dangerous
it could be dangerous in the sense that
people could see with they're doing and
they would try to capture them or it
could be that they may tap into a a
power that they can't control but more
so than that and more importantly to Dr
Doom than that the uh energy that he's
detected here is something that's very
important something that that can't be
denied because what it is is it's it's
the combination of five particular
artifacts now he doesn't tell us what
these five artifacts are but what he
says is that one of them is enough power
to uh lay waste to the entire universe
but five of them being combined into one
massive power source is something that
would allow Dr Doom along with this
individual that he's speaking to to
implement their grand plans of taking
over the entire universe and quite
possibly other universes and so what
this learn what we learn here is that
this person that Dr Doom is talking to
is King the Conqueror who has traveled
to the 20th century for the purpose of
combining his efforts with Dr Doom to
allow the both of them to go about their
plans of Conquest now what we also do is
we switch to Monster Island to the home
of moleman man and what we have here is
a a scenario where the infinity watch
has basically turned this place into a
uh into a headquarters of sorts but it's
done with a very tenuous agreement with
moleman now we don't exactly know what
the agreement was that was made between
mman and warlock but whatever this
agreement was is a is a such degree that
it allows Warlock and the infinity watch
to use this place as a as a base of
operations but it also allows mman to
continue his schemes to a degree to the
sense that he's able to go about the
process of maintaining his Endeavors but
only in so far that it doesn't come into
conflict with the actions of the
infinity watch but what we also find out
here is that there's another person
that's joined this group and this person
that's joined them is Thanos now
initially the idea here may be at least
as far as the infinity watch is
concerned that Thanos has perhap perhaps
come by to seek retribution that he may
actually uh be here to try to capture
their infinity gems but what Thanos
tells us here is that he's not here to
fight any of them that what he's here
for is their help indicating he is going
to enlist the aid of the infinity watch
to help him uh defeat the Magus but that
being said I will catch you guys later
[Music]
peace
he